some of you might remember the math
metal song we did based around the
golden reissue where we took the digits
of Phi the golden ratio map them onto
various scales map them onto various
rhythms even involved the lyrics and
that was like a huge amount of fun but I
think Brady lost some subscribers
because for some strange reason not
everybody is a heavy metal fan it's I
don't know why that is so what what I
did instead was I decided to do
something which is actually far removed
from metal there's a little bit of
guitar and what you're about to hear but
not very much very subtle very gentle
tones piano strings interweaving and
what I've done is I've sampled very hard
voice there's a great video in one of
our videos from time she actually sings
the notes and she got this crystal-clear
bear like tone in a voice it's it's it's
really quite nice so I've incorporated
that in this what this actually is is a
mixture of Phi the golden ratio and tau
and scales based on those and pretty
with somewhere add a link to a detailed
description if you're musically inclined
about that
[Music]
so that first bit those no.2 based
around time
and it's coming in a background I'm low
note signals where I'm going to
introduce in a second to notes due to
the golden ratio which are they in the
background
I wish I had a piano in front of me I
don't so that those notes algorithm are
the first three digits of the golden
ratio played on top of that riff which
is rising from the notes of time digit
of time
and the strings also digits as well
[Music]
so coming in here is a cameo by
something called lateralis by a band
called too
you're mentioned a lot and here comes
very focus
[Music]
so I've had to do strange things with
the sampling and the effects and
frequency shifting to get it into the
right pitch but I really just I'll play
advise vocals again because they are
really quite neat if I can find the
channel so six to eight etc are the
digital Tao toupee and in the
description under the video somewhere
down here braid you and link to a longer
description see if your accuracy so we
define angles counterclockwise so we go
that way so rather than that way it's
the property of time look you want the
hugs here you don't want hard over there
things also no one harms here because
the ha